insulation automatically
additionally we know that in past uh in
the past loan servicers placed borrowers
who are struggling to manage repayment
into forbearances without giving them
adequate information about alternatives
and that meant in forbearance while no
payments were due interest continued to
accrue and borrowers did not get credit
toward idr forgiveness this is often not
the best option for borrowers
particularly when they would be eligible
for an economic hardship deferment or a
low or zero payment on an idr plan and
to make sure that existing borrowers
aren't permanently harmed by these
failures the department will apply
pslf and idr credit for borrowers who
ended up in long term forbearance those
are forbearances of 12 or more
consecutive months or 36 or more total
months so important steps on that front
last thing i just wanted to note um and
you may have seen this but this morning
the department of treasury
sanctioned trans trans capital bank a
key russian commercial bank that has
offered services to banks globally to
evade international sanctions and more
than 40 individuals and entities that
are part of a russian sanctions evasion
network led by russian oligarch
constantine mulliphaev we have also
imposed sanctions on companies in
russia's virtual currency mining
industry that operate vast server farms
and provide revenue to the russian
government and the department of state
imposed visa restrictions on more than
600 individuals in response to human
rights abuses by russia and belarus so
this is part of our stepped-up effort to
crack down on those attempting to evade
our unprecedented sanctions with that
darlene won't you kick us off thank you
a couple of questions on asking
the president said yesterday that people
should decide for themselves whether to
wear masks on airplanes and wondering
whether his comment was uh intended to
signal a shift in thinking in the
administration
away from
mandates for
more personal responsibility
the question the president was answering
the question quite literally which means
right now as you know we are not
implementing the mask mandate because of
the court order which we disagree with
while he is still abiding by cdc
guidance and we recommend americans do
that across the country they're still
recommending people wear masks on
airplanes on air force one which of
course is a federal not a private plane
we all wore masks on the plane when we
traveled to new hampshire yesterday but
we are not
people are not legally bound to wear
masks so it is a point in time where
where it is up to people it is their
choice uh
in that regard and then one other
question actually on a different topic
in the interest of crime here today are
you able to confirm reports that the
president is replacing the acting atf
director with another gentleman who will
also be the acting atf director until
the person he nominated last week is
confirmed by the senate
uh yes so i know there have been reports
about this out there and i will say that
the president is making the designation
under the vacancies reform act which of
course
says that any president um and only the
president may direct a person who serves
in an office for which appointment is
required to be made by the president by
and with the advice of consent of senate
to perform the functions and duties of
the vacant office temporarily we of
course are strongly advocating for and
pushing for his uh eminently qualified
nominee uh to be confirmed and have an
atf uh confirmed director for the first
time in many years which is something we
would be eager to see happen
on the the long-range missile test today
says this is
meant to provide food for thought for
those who threaten russia can you talk
us through how the administration is
interpreting this and whether you're
viewing this as a warning or a threat in
any way
uh we are not they were they notified um
under uh the start treaty
and so from our perspective while we
they provide advanced notice of this
launch under its new start treaty
obligations that have planned to test
this missile the defense department said
today that we did not deem the test a
threat to the united states or its
allies and the timing and the scope of
russia's missile tests do not influence
our approach to countering russia's
further invasion of ukraine so it was
noticed through the proper process and
the department of defense has spoken to
this as well and on uh an expected
announcement of another round of
assistance to ukraine could you walk us
through any specifics if you have any on
that when that's happening and and just
big picture on this the us has already
given more than 2.5 billion since this
war started how long can the us
expect to continue to bankroll so much
of this war well um okay there's a
couple questions there so let me do my
best in answering them
first
we are working
of course around the clock as you know
to provide security assistance to
ukraine and just to give you an example
of how
that assistance has flowed just in the
last few days and i think i gave an
update the other day but
five flights with military assistance
have arrived in the region over the last
few days more than half a dozen flights
from the united states are scheduled to
land in the region shortly with
additional equipment and as we look at
the providing this assistance which i
know i'll go back to the first part of
your question of course but what we've
tried to do we made a strategic decision
given we've seen russia um reposition uh
their troops and their military to the
eastern part of ukraine to fight a
different kind of war on the ground
which will be more uh you know um
kind of uh shooting back and forth
through long range and so we have been
working with ukrainians in the ukrainian
military to determine exactly the kind
of security assistance they need for
this stage in the war and that has
included an increase as you've seen in
artillery and ammunition and uh weapons
like howitzers and others that can do
these sort of the can are effective in
this long-range shooting and long-range
fighting that we are seeing or we
anticipate will happen in this stage of
the war so we have been
expediting this assistance to the ground
over the last couple of weeks to ensure
they are prepared as this as this
portion of the war is starting not
because they are using all of it in in
seven days but because we want them to
have all of this equipment as quickly as
possible as they prepare to fight this
war on the ground uh in terms of
assistance in what we would be what
we're preparing with the reports that i
know have been out there um i will say i
expect we'll have more soon on this but
i have nothing to preview at this point
in time i would note that out of the 3.5
billion dollars in drawdown authority
congress granted for this fiscal year we
have used over 2.4 billion so far to
provide ukraine the military equipment
and capabilities they need to defend
themselves so obviously there's more of
that approved drawdown assistance that
we can provide and we've been working to
expedite and ensure as i noted it's
meeting exactly the needs they have at
this point in the war
go ahead a couple quick ones on uh mask
the update um the doj said yesterday
that
they would decide essentially whether or
not to appeal
that ruling
based on what the cdc says they need or
don't need um is the white house or the
cabinet involved in any way in that
decision-making process
well we we are um entirely able to and
legally able to be a part of the
discussion but uh right now it's we of
course are deferring to the cdc on what
they believe is needed at this moment
they've already have they obviously put
in place this two-week extension because
they felt they needed that to take a
look at the data given that we've seen a
rise in cases so we certainly anticipate
to hear more from them soon on their ask
for uh for being able to have that time
which we think is entirely warranted and
the department of justice as you noted
has indicated uh that they would appeal
not just because they think it's
entirely reasonable
of course to have this additional time
to look at it but because they think uh
that the current uh for current and
future public health crises we want to
preserve that that
authority for the cdc to have in the
future and then just uh when you said a
moment ago that it that it literally is
a personal choice as to whether people
are deciding to put a mask on or not on
planes is it
does that
messaging still reflect um a shift for
you all and and maybe to some degree a
capitulation to just the mood of the
public about wanting to be over this
pandemic or people who have politicized
the wearing of masks in the first place
well first i would say we continue to
recommend everyone wear masks on planes
what the president was speaking to is of
course because we are not currently
implementing the mask mandate it is not
a requirement so people can choose even
as we recommend it but to be clear we
are recommending everyone wear masks on
planes that is what the cdc is
recommending that is the public health
guidance we are following i would note i
know this is often said and maybe some
of it is because
there was the video of people on planes
on the plane on one plane taking off
their masks public polling does not
actually show that there is a universal
view of people getting rid of masks
that's not actually what public polling
shows now it doesn't matter to us
because we are making our decisions
based on public health
and data and what the cdc is
recommending but that is not the
universal view of the public
go ahead jen um a ukrainian commander in
mary opal
is saying that his forces and civilians
in the area may only have hours to make
it out alive and he has been making this
directly to the president for the u.s to
somehow be involved in extracting people
from the area do you know if that's a
request that the president himself is
aware of and can you just walk us
through can the us be directly involved
at this point in making that happen or
helping to make that happen sure we have
certainly seen um these these cries for
help and these ask for help would we
certainly urge the russian government to
do the right thing guarantee safe
passage for any civilians or others who
wish to leave the city
we also encourage them to allow
deliveries of humanitarian aid such as
food and medicine and safe passage for
volunteers to help people in need but i
don't have any additional updates from
here um and quickly on uh the president
and whether he might visit ukraine
you've obviously said a couple of times
currently there are no plans to do that
yesterday when he was asked are you
going he said he wasn't sure
is a trip completely off the table for
now for him nothing has changed in our
assessment i would also note as i've
said in here before
if anyone were to visit ukraine uh from
the united states it's not something we
would announce in advance confirm in
advance give details on who if and when
uh because of security reasons and
that's something i think anyone who's
traveled to a war zone with a president
or a vice president or anyone is quite
familiar with that policy
he didn't know was he trying to indicate
that i think he's changing our plans
yeah one more question um there are
obviously so many horrific images coming
out of ukraine they're very readily
available photographs videos of civilian
deaths
as we enter the third
month of this conflict can you walk us
through give us a sense of how the
president himself has been sort of
processing these images who does he talk
to what does he lean on
as he processes images that you know
coming from what he himself is called
the genocide yeah look i will say that
um the president is processing these
images as many americans are with horror
with sadness um with um you know
fear for the people of ukraine for the
families for the children for innocent
civilians who are at risk um
it is uh obviously this conflict is
consuming a great deal of his time as as
much as he is working on a range of
other priorities here um but uh he is
consuming them as many people are as i
am as many of you are as americans out
there watching all of your networks are
uh it's emotional um it is uh you know
watching some of these images is very
raw for people including the president
because uh you're seeing people
suffering
at the hands of a dictator who is
brutally uh targeting civilians go ahead
a few in ukraine for you the fact that
the u.s is committing heavier weapons
systems
than it did initially indicate that
there's
less at least in the assessment of the
united states less risk of retaliation
from russia now
the the types of weapons systems we're
providing that are really a reflection
of the conversations happening with
ukrainian leadership and military about
what they need in this stage of the war
and because the stage of the war is
different because it's going to be more
on the ground
and more uh more um kind of uh back and
forth long-range fighting there's
different kinds of weapons and system
they need more artillery more ammunition
it's a different
different war than it was uh when they
were uh you know in the western part of
the country it said earlier that you
uh the government's continuing to
monitor
that whatever is sent over is meeting
the needs of the war
how exactly is that monitoring happening
there gonna be a lot of questions about
how was the money spent
who did the equipment get in the hands
of how was it used it may not be
in the next few weeks but this year over
the next several months or years of was
this worth it was it worth the cost how
is that being done now well look i think
that um if you ask most americans if you
ask members of congress if you ask most
people in this country uh what we what's
important to do now is to equip and
provide the type of support assistance
including military equipment to help
them continue to fight and and win in
some cases as they did in the battle of
kiev this war um that is our focus
obviously we coordinate very closely
with them but we provide them the
assistance to distribute uh amongst
their military because there was support
in the beginning of the iraq war in the
afghanistan war and then there were
years spent
trying to retrace the spending and all
that i'm not saying that necessarily
going to be the case in this one but no
mechanism in place right now at least i
i would point you to the department of
defense to detail that further but i
would know obviously this is different
given we don't have u.s soldiers on the
ground um obviously equipment ensuring
we're reducing waste fraud and abuse is
important to the president but it's a
different kind of war for a range of
reasons given that russia has conducted
an icbm test is there any plan to
reschedule the one that we cancelled uh
back on april 1st uh that's not
something we would preview
and what's the latest on the reported
chemical weapons attack
did the russians use chemical weapons
there's no new assessment from here
when or how much longer that would take
i don't i mean what we talked about at
the time and i know my colleagues at the
department of defense and state also
referenced as we don't have a team on
the ground it is it is difficult to
assess so it is something certainly we
continue to work to do but we don't have
any additional updates or confirmation
go ahead thanks jen i have a question
about marijuana policy
president biden is a candidate uh
promised to decriminalize marijuana when
is that going to happen
well
the president continues to believe that
no one should be in jail
because of drug use i don't have an
update here we are continuing to work
with congress but what i can say on
marijuana is we've made some progress
on our promises for instance the dea
just issued its first licenses to
companies to cultivate marijuana for
research purposes after years of delay
during the prior administration this is
a key step in promoting research because
it broadens the amount and quality of
cannabis available for research purposes
additionally the president's continuing
to view his clement review his clemency
powers which is something he also talked
about on the campaign and certainly
remains committed to taking action on so
he remains committed to what he said
during the campaign that people charged
with marijuana related offenses number
one everybody gets out record expunged
well again he's reviewing his clemency
powers that's exactly what that looks
like i don't have any updates or
previews beyond that though okay a
question about immigration does the
president still have confidence that the
vice president can get to the bottom of
root causes of migration
he absolutely does and uh and is
grateful for her work in doing exactly
that why
why does he have confidence or should i
should i give you an update on a couple
of the things we've done what gives the
president confidence uh when he sees
that march 2022 has 28
more migrant encounters at the border
than march 2021 when she got this
assignment well you asked me about root
causes right so let me address that
first and what the vice president and
other members of the administration have
been working with or have been doing so
we've been working with source and
transit
countries in the region to facilitate
the quick return of individuals who
previously resided in those countries as
well as to stem migration in its state
some of that is getting agreements with
partner countries on migration related
matters and that's something that the
vice president has been deeply engaged
with i'd also note that secretary
muricus who of course has worked with
her on this traveled to costa rica
recently where he joined the president
of costa rica and announcing a bilateral
migration agreement outlining our shared
commitment to both manage migrant flows
as well as to promote economic growth in
the region and we also are maintaining a
close partnership between the government
of mexico and the united states to send
a regular migration so they're what
addressing root causes means is working
with countries in the region to take
steps to uh to have partnership be able
to have people sent back uh to the
region as needed and then the last one
is the president or are you guys having
discussions with advisors about delaying
the removal of title 42
well i would again remind everyone
because you gave me the opportunity so
thank you title 42 is not an immigration
authority i will i will get you i will i
will get to your question i promise
peter um it is a public health authority
congress gave the cdc authority to make
determinations about when it should be
lifted so right now we are planning and
preparing for the end of title 42
enforcement on may 23rd but i would say
that there are a range the president
agrees that immigration in our country
is broken it's a system that is broken
there are a range of ideas out there in
congress democrats republicans others
some who support a delay of title 42
implementation some who strongly oppose
it and there are a range of other ideas
of reforming our immigration system this
would all require congressional action
we're happy to have that conversation
with them
excuse me sorry it's allergies it's okay
we understand
we understand
um we've been reporting that the
administration is projecting a big
budget shortfall
for ice and cbp
should title 42 be lifted
um is there a plan for how to get
additional funding that's going to be
needed
to handle immigrants coming into the
country if that title 42 is lifted will
you need funds for congress can you
divert funds from somewhere else what's
the thinking so what dhs said last month
is that they expect the current funding
levels will not be sufficient to meet
operational needs but they have a number
of options available to secure the
resources required to implement our
comprehensive strategy this includes
reprioritizing and reallocating existing
funds rigs requesting additional support
from other federal agencies if necessary
engaging with congress uh on that
discussion and i would note that as a
part of this you know as we prepare for
the implementation as of the end of
title 42 there are a range of steps that
we've been taking to prepare for that
including surging resources
deploying resistor resources to address
increased volumes that includes moving
officers agents dhs volunteer force
personnel to rapidly decompress points
along the border and more efficiently
processed migrants it also entails the
deployment of covid19 mitigation efforts
including the use of continued use of
ppe providing the covet 19 vaccines it
also includes expanding these efforts to
cover migrants in cbp custody so point
is there a range of steps in this
comprehensive plan that i know secretary
marcus is testifying today on the hill
and i'm sure he'll be testifying more in
the future but what they said at the
time when we announced this was that we
expect current funding levels would not
be sufficient there are a range of ways
to address that and we're working on
exactly that and
if because we're just about a month away
from this being elected if the
administration doesn't feel like that
plan is in place yet
would that be a reason to delay lifting
title 42. well we've proposed a plan so
that's a plan that is being implemented
uh in terms of any ideas to address
immigration including any delay of title
42 that would require congressional
action so
go ahead
more than 3 000 ukrainians were
processed along the southern border
people who had flown to mexico to try to
get into the u.s
that's a big leap over february that
number is expected to increase does the
administration have any plans to
announce a program that would make it
easier for ukrainians who already have
family ties in the us to be expedited to
the us we are we are working so we've
obviously announced the president has
announced plans to accept a hundred
thousand ukrainians um into the united
states if they want to come of course
we're working to finalize the details of
that of course right now we are still as
you all know as we've been talking about
implementing title 42 no matter what
country you're coming from whether it's
ukraine or any other country in the
world sure but nothing is there anything
immediately in the works for a plan a
program similar to that well no the
president announced a few weeks ago
plans to welcome a hundred thousand
ukrainian uh
ukrainians right so it's just the
details of how that program will work i
understand what you're asking we just
don't have the final details yet but on
supply chains millions of people in
china are on lockdown experts are
sounding the alarm for what that could
mean for further crippling supply chains
which already are obviously are already
under strain um is the administration
concerned how concerned is the
administration about what that could
mean for americans waiting for goods
here in the us is there anything that
the u.s can do to mitigate that sure so
this is a very fluid and i think you're
talking about the lock down around
shanghai right and the impact so it's a
very fluid situation obviously um
there's some uncertainty surrounding the
impacts of china's lockdown on our
economy uh we are in close contact with
key actors in the supply chain including
the ports of los angeles and long beach
we're not seeing currently according to
the port of la any slow down in ships
coming from asia but we're going to
continue to keep our eye on that what
we've seen happen within china is moving
of the manufacturing of some of the
goods semiconductors consumer
electronics etc that are coming
typically come from shanghai to other
hubs moving them around to see if they
can keep the manufacturing up uh and
they've also moved ports and we're moved
around where the where the goods are
going from in ports there which may be
why we haven't seen a reduction in goods
coming from asia the last data in terms
of chinese exports we have is from march
because it's not at the end of april and
that showed a 15 increase from last year
but we'll have to look at the april data
when it comes out in may go ahead
um i might be being a little thick but i
still don't quite understand what the
administration's position on
the how you're kind of approaching the
mask
issue is so
the justice department said that they
would appeal the decision if the cdc
wanted them to yeah the cdc has said
that they
wanted masks they still think masking is
important and that they had that policy
in place so i don't understand why
the justice department is not
immediately appealing it and especially
seeking an emergency stay to
uh potentially
keep this in place while the cdc
continues sort of broader evaluation
sure well i'm i don't even play a lawyer
on tv um so i won't get too much into
legal strategy but what i will tell you
is uh the cdc obviously as you noted um
called for this extension because they
wanted to look at more data so i think
we can all expect they're going to
continue to want it the department of
justice is just waiting for that kind of
final
comment um to to take action and
appealing they said they would appeal in
terms of when they will appeal i'll
leave that to them to speak to why not a
stay or an emergency appeal they can
speak to that but what i would note the
objective here is of course to appeal
the 15 day extension but also to
preserve the cdc authority over the long
term because as we've noted from here we
expect there to be ups and downs in the
pandemic and we certainly want the cdc
to continue to have this authority
and
i guess plain english if the cdc
determines at the end of that 15-day
review period that they already had
undergoing that they wouldn't confuse
mass mandate then the justice department
will not
uh pursue this appeal
i would expect you'll hear from the cdc
very soon and i don't think it's at the
end of 15 days in terms of their
expectation and ask for an appeal on
title 42 um
you kind of floated um
congressional action out there and this
is permanent because
title 42 i think was a key part of the
uh
and scuttling the negotiations of
recovered money and so what i'm trying
to i think
the question i'm curious in is if you're
signaling a sort of willingness by the
administration to
negotiate over
the lifting of 10 42 as part of uh
trying to get that copic package offline
and if not
if so do you have any sort of update on
the strategy there because you you were
certainly banging the drums about how
important it was before congress went
away and
they're coming back soon we're still
banging the drums about the covet money
i promise you um
i was just making clear because i think
there's been some confusion about this
that um well the cdc had the has the
authority right to determine when uh the
the um
when when the conditions exist to lift
title 42 uh that was given to them by
congress if congress were to want to
extend that
it they need to take action it's not a
it's not a executive authority from from
uh from the white house the president
would be open to legislation that
provided coveted funding but also uh
extended
we're not in any way there so i wasn't
going there i was just conveying that as
you know there are strong views on a
range of immigration
issues and proposals in congress right
i'm not telling you something you don't
know there are some people who would
like to see it extended there are some
people who definitely would not and so
i'm not making a prediction of the
future only conveying to what authority
would be required what what the process
would require
would the white house support um
the bill that senator cinema is
is bringing forth which is working to
extend
title 42
until there's a plan in place
i don't have any prediction of that the
president has proposed put forward
called for immigration reform something
he did on his first day in office we're
happy to have a range of conversations
with members about a range of ideas uh
but
i just wanted to know what authority
would be required or what how the
process would work go ahead uh two
things um south korean media is
reporting that president biden will
visit the country next month may 20th
through the 22nd can you confirm that i
don't have anything to confirm yet on
the trip beyond what the president
himself has already confirmed but we
will have more to say soon i'm sure
um and on covet 8 i'm wondering if the
administration has sort of a
a drop death date by which congress has
to give them the additional funding i
know you've talked about it the um
the supply of monopoly antibodies will
run out in may yeah and the test uh
capacity will ramp down by the end of
june so is junior deadline or is it much
earlier or is it later if you can
repurpose some of the existing money uh
i would say it's as soon as possible
because we're we have already had to
take steps right like ending our program
for the uninsured
we haven't been able to make purchases
that we would normally purchase to get
ahead i mean even on monoclonal
antibodies
or some of these treatments some of them
take months to make so it already puts
us behind where we need to be and want
to be in planning
so we don't have a
long-term deadline nor would i punt that
out we want to do it as quickly as
possible when they return
thanks jim
several senators democrats and
republican um have called on the
president to appoint a coordinator or a
czar if you will to oversee the transfer
of military equipment from the u.s to
ukraine
what does the administration think of
this idea
do you think it's stated and is it
something that's even being considered i
don't have any personnel updates
obviously ensuring that it is kind of
goes back to ed's earlier question that
it is done effectively efficiently
quickly um is is is as a priority for
the president but um i don't have any um
any personnel previews or updates at
this point in time go ahead two
questions i wanted to ask you about the
concept of athletic boycotts to deal
with russia and if this is something
that the administration supports
actually saw some of the news that
wimbledon decided to ban uh athletes
from russia and belarus re-competing in
the tournament i'm just curious if the
administration believes the athletic
boycotts are a good tactic to use we've
seen
600 if not more companies private sector
companies um pull out voluntarily i
think um
their investments in russia um
i don't
i don't think we have a policy
specifically on athletic events at this
point in time i'm happy to check
and then also there were reports that
treasury secretary janet yellen and some
other u.s officials walked out of g20
rules when russian officials began
speaking
could you just explain a little bit more
about why they took that move and is it
a move that we could anticipate
president biden making himself
well the president and secretary yellen
have both said that we can't have
business as usual at the g20 or in a lot
of these international forums as it
relates to russia and uh she uh and and
the treasury team made clear that she
was planning to participate in some and
not other meetings uh which certainly
something we support the president also
is conveyed he doesn't believe that they
should be a part that russia should be a
part of the g20 that's now six months
away in terms of his participation so i
can't make a prediction of what actions
he may or may not take but
certainly we support her steps and it's
an indication of
of the fact that president putin and
russia has become a pariah on the global
stage
good thank you
uh just today russia is issued another
uh warning about consequences of finland
and sweden joining nato do you have a
response
well uh the decision of any country to
join nato is up to that country and nato
uh to make a determination about uh and
certainly that's the case here uh we
strongly support nato's open door policy
um and i'm not gonna indulge uh russia's
saber rattling go ahead thank you
um just to zoom out a bit on the ukraine
yeah aid and the policy tours sure this
war
um the uh the president european council
charles michelle said today
um and he said
which was unusually clear said you are
not alone we are with you and we'll do
everything which is possible to support
you and to make sure the ukraine will
win the war
is it the policy of the united states
that russia should
not only lose but be seen to lose this
war without a strategic goal i think
we've been pretty clear that we're going
to do everything possible to make sure
president putin and russia
recognize this is a strategic loss that
the president is a pariah on the global
stage
now when you have a country that has
lost
uh as many people as ukraine has
millions of people have been left
homeless uh you know i don't know if
that feels like a win to them but i
think it's also true that the ukrainians
have clearly won the battle of kiev they
have surpassed the expectations of the
world in terms of their ability to fight
back against russia and russia has not
only
become a pariah on the world stage but
they have effectively united nato
effectively driven countries to to
desire an interest in joining nato have
united the west in a way that has never
been their objective while also their
economy is crumbling so you know that
is all uh a victory in terms of um of in
terms of uh isolating russia this is the
concrete goal of the aid that's going
there now it's an artillery and more
uh is the goal of battlefield defeat for
russia ultimately not not a compromise
not not
no gray areas just
we're doing everything we can to equip
the ukrainian government ukrainian
leaders to uh effectively fight back in
this military battle
go ahead thanks jen just to go back to
the mass ruling um you mentioned some of
the videos that we saw but it certainly
did prompt some very abrupt changes on
monday uh after it came down passengers
being told mid-flight to take their
masks off can you share more about what
the president's personal reaction was uh
to the decision uh to how it came down
and what unfolded over those couple of
hours and the stories we're hearing
about some of those flights
i i'm not sure we have a story here
about some of those flights
that we're hearing now about parents
talking about being on a flight with
their kids and then being concerned
because they were mid-flight but just
what was his reaction to the decision
and
what happened then over the next couple
of hours on monday well we obviously
didn't expect the decision because uh we
wouldn't have known in advance how a
court act
so
and we disagreed with the decision
immediately so uh the immediate steps
were to determine uh what power we had
to respond to that obviously that uh
that uh came in the form of the
department of justice came in the form
of the cdc acting um
and putting out the statements that they
did but um you know we also don't take
photos of flights as data about how the
country reacts to issues um you know as
whether they're ripping off their their
masks or not i mean our focus here was
seeing what power we had to preserve uh
what we felt was in the public health
interests of the country the president's
coveted advisor's concern that there
could be
an increase in cases of spiking cases in
the coming weeks because
specifically the mass mandate being
lifted well i'm not going to make a
projection of that because i'm not a
doctor um and certainly i can check with
our health team and see if they have any
predictions of that obviously they
wanted more time because they've seen
rising cases and they feel it is in our
interest to preserve the mass command
date even for that short period of time
or have the authority moving forward in
case cases go up and uh and we needed to
take that step in the future but i i
don't have a prediction of rising cases
i would point you to the cdc or other
health officials uh go ahead jen uh
there are reports that mexico media is
stating that the mexican government has
decided to dismantle a bi-national
police group that was fighting mexican
cartels or drug cartel operations down
there i wonder if the administration is
aware of that and if you have any
reaction to that i'm happy to check with
our nsc team and see if they have any
specific reaction go ahead thanks uh
first of all on israel does the
administration have a reaction to the
recent deadly clashes in israel with
palestinians does it change your stance
on the abrahamic court or you have a
different view now on how to achieve
peace in that region
we are well we are deeply concerned by
the recent violence in jerusalem um at
the temple mount on the temple mount and
across the west bank we also strongly
condemn the recent rocket attack on
israel we continue to call on all sides
to exercise restraint avoid provocative
actions and rhetoric and preserve the
historic status quo of the harem sharif
temple mount we also continue to urge
israeli and palestinian officials to
work cooperatively to lower tensions and
ensure the safety of everyone and we of
course continue to closely follow the
situation on the ground and stay in
touch through diplomatic channels does
it change your stance on the abraham
accords or there is no change on our on
our stance
as you know administration officials are
meeting with cuba to discuss maybe
including them again in migration policy
what might that look like in the future
and is that a possibility well i would
say that we see these talks as pretty
standard um the migration talks provide
an opportunity for discussions on
migration issues between qb and then qb
in the united states and they're part of
regular order meetings continuing over
nearly 30 years of engagement on cuba
with cuba on migration matters
we maintain um
we maintain these in order to discuss
safe orderly and legal migration that
remains a primary us of primary us
interest um so beyond what they will
look like i mean to us this is just a
standard operating um process and
discussions that have been happening
over the course of many years the last
ones were of course in 2018. finally
just on some of the munitions being sent
to ukraine how does the administration
justify sending claymore munitions which
critics say
are quite dangerous and in their
anti-personnel mine form have been
banned by 160 countries including
ukraine
i'd point at the department of defense
to speak to any specifics of the
military equipment or assistance we're
providing obviously we're providing this
to a country that is facing an invasion
by russia that is targeting their
civilians and their people
and this is meant to effectively help
them fight that war thanks everyone
[Music]
i got
i